Developers have
strong opinions when
it comes to things like
performance and optimization.
So when it came time for
me to launch a series,
I wanted to get involved in
something non-controversial,
something that we, as
programmers, all agree on,
without hard feeling or rancor.
Now if I know anything, it's
that like operating systems,
"Star Wars" versus "Star Trek,"
and how to pronounce GIF,
you'll never find
two engineers arguing
over the ideal developer tools
and development environment.
Take Colt and Ian here.
When using C++, Colt likes
vi and Ian uses Emacs,
but they're still great friends.
In Android Tool Time, I'll
be exploring the world
of Android developer tools.
I'll focus on Android
Studio, checking out
new tools, undiscovered
features, pro tips,
and get expert advice directly
from the Android Studio team.
And of course, we'll go
in-depth into each new release
of Android Studio,
including finding out
what's in this entirely
nondescript and non-ominous
box.
I'm Reto Meier.
Join me on the Android
Developers YouTube channel
as we talk developer tools,
the least controversial topic
in computer science.
It's Android Tool Time time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]